situation's a simulation it's just what
it is cause
listen it's one of those things well
first of all i just want to say
i just want to say um hello to
um uh michelle obama yes she
it was a couple weeks ago but you get a
fantastic fierce
speech at the dnc and it's just amazing
to see you girl
save your drama from michelle obama guys
guys other podcasts they like to strike
low
here at the history hyenas we go high
yes why do we go high because we don't
want to contribute
to being having to put ourselves on
on us so we go
high we go so high we can touch the sky
you do this next time you see somebody
you know not
next time you see somebody appropriating
someone's culture next time you see
someone misgendering someone next time
you see someone using
a plastic straw next time you see
someone outwardly saying that they
may just a slight possibility be voting
for donald trump
you look them in the face and you say
you my friend are on
uh you are nude ass
notice you're naughty you're on notice
cause
we go high we go high yeah we don't go
for low humor
we don't go for low blues yeah we go
high
flotus and potus you're on notice yes
everyone's on [ __ ] notice everyone no
you curt you weren't supposed to curse
in the five minutes you [ __ ] thought
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's what it is cuz we're gonna do an
interview today later with chip
chipperson but the fans don't want to
hear about
it we tried to go on patreon.com and do
a [ __ ] scandal and try to jump up to
patreon
but the fans don't cure anymore because
they've just had enough for the [ __ ]
the truth of the situation is this my
friends
is that a lot of people are just [ __ ]
dumb idiots
most of us have had enough most of us
are like listen
we want the police back that's what most
of us are saying it's character
we not clip it i mean edit it sorry
i thought i thought that's what most of
us were saying
sorry no the people in the middle don't
want to give too much they don't want to
give too little they want to give just
enough to keep it moving
yeah right now the people who are in the
middle are have been pulled to the to
the front in the back of the boat
yeah and the middle is is
empty yeah and it's a nice place to be
in the middle
middle is a mesh patel concert on the
ship
the mesh patella is by the way at this
point it's just a joke
he said he said he's coming on he wants
to come on we don't want him on
no i want him on i want to mesh patel on
and i yeah i want the mesh picture just
kidding
i don't know it's all this is all a joke
it's all a joke because i'm in the
middle i comfortably live in the middle
i'm essential so i'm christy the
centrist i live in the middle
politically
i live in the middle with my sexuality
and i live in the middle of vanity's
love affair
so i'm just in the middle yes yes yes
yes
and um you know you guys everyone's
going on dates and i just we're all in
love
listen yeah listen we're all going on i
went on a date
last week i went on a date last week and
then i'm just
canceling uh the date we're supposed to
have today and vanity has managed me for
canceling
but i just have to cancel characters the
thing about you
is it she needs she said i need to be
honest well listen sister
the truth is i think you're a great
person but i just can't do it right now
i have too much anxiety got too many
things going on
i got to paint the baby's room i got to
paint the baby's room
and i'm just questioning the truth is is
i would go on a second date if if
you if it you show up uh and it's your
brother wild
[Laughter]
you're just you're interested in cute
guys you're sitting cute man
you're just not yeah i mean you just
can't bear you guys don't even bury the
gay and [ __ ]
so the text that i sent giannis uh last
uh the other day earnestly you know
and while you see my feelings yes and
then yeah i said uh
where is that i said um really funny
is it i said to yana yes you got to
scroll back through a lot of my text
through a lot
yeah yeah oh i well i said and this was
true i said i was in panatiko
which is our um hardcore bay ridge
italian goomba cafe and i was sitting
with my daughter and i overheard a man
say exactly this
i banged a barbarian last night because
when she took her shirt off i thought i
was gonna have to power washer
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to patreon.com
where things get really wild